previously on TV since the game Rachel
the game you always money for the game
he beats me straight-up play him paid
that me and his money bearish ugly font
reading that's right like called the
American Horror Story font ugly
seriously the upper circle on that eight
is closed up tighter than a nun's finger
during Mardi Gras this is all wrong
everyone knows that you should apply
your blood below the apples of the
cheeks and blend out to the hairline
just look at this water bottle shaming
can someone check on the camera person
they seem to be a little woozy
or at least a little overly angular and
a very Dutch sort of way
well my pets and you all miss this Kathy
Bates Motel intro is laying the racism
on so thick they should have just named
this seasoned American Horror Story
extreme racism edition I'm not saying
racism isn't totally worth calling out
as horrific I'm just saying when you
make it this gross and sensationalistic
it may keep us from addressing the
actual issue itself I'll rip your lips
open and stuff more being there this
reminds me of a story with my college
girlfriend where she decided to stuff I
[Music]
brush my teeth for a few days and I
still tasted purple crayon for another
month darling you have outdone yourself
however did you think you saw
circle-jerk conversation from the
writers room accidentally finds its way
into the script the mannitol was always
my favorite man half bull actually its
body of a man and the head of a bull so
a more like 3/4 man and one quarter bull
no really I think we could consider the
whole thing 100% bull since they were
concerned about getting caught in their
tryst I would suggest not making out in
disrobing right in front of a large
glass sliding door just sex being
somebody's first what sexy talk like
that it's no wonder she wanted you to be
her first a kid gets a bloody nose and
dies of a brain aneurysm when he tries
to have premarital sex said script
supervisor Mike Pence you
great-grandmother had the same genetic
affliction vagina dentata I'm sorry baby
we can't keep you here anymore it's too
dangerous
I guess alien invasions were currently
down but witches being reborn was
currently up so the MIB were brought in
to assist a Ryan Murphy thought suits
and sunglasses would make this scene a
little more suspenseful and less stupid
but he was wrong and in this shot
everyone just stay
around as she slowly approaches the gate
because reality we've got a cool over
the gate crane shot too while you with
so we're Six Feet Under and discount
Slim Shady ghosts and was the car she
arrived and also a ghost well any other
speed answered well any of this be
explained do I care
miss robichaux's Academy for exceptional
young ladies it's like the x-mansion but
with overplayed horror cliches and the
mutant powers are just unexplained demon
ah sudden gonzo also I would give all
the sins back if we found out the
teachers at this Academy were the
Muppets and they performed happiness
hotel to welcome so me just to clarify
she saw this and decided to further
explore the school she's a Sabrina relax
we'll handle the witchy nicknames
ourselves or whiny Granger also even as
far as dumb pranks on horror television
shows go that was one of the most video
double ones to wait miss robichaux's
Academy for exceptional young ladies was
established as a premier girls finishing
school in 1790 mr. Robicheau is Academy
for expositional young ladies
establishing a safe haven where young
witches could gather to learn what's
called the Freiburg Dance Academy but
don't tell your uncle Dario about it so
what happened to her the same thing
that's happened to women like us
throughout the centuries but how is she
even found out in the scene we saw there
is no way this woman that looked over at
her could have seen anything other than
a bird flying from Misty's hand maybe it
was alive the whole time there was no
way for this woman to know otherwise
Allegra suffers from acute bradycardia
her kidneys are failing you sure she's
not just suffering from sneezing itchy
eyes and a runny nose would seem to fit
better also is he saying that
bradycardia is the term we used for
kidney failure because that's a sinan
even if he's saying that Allegra is
suffering from bradycardia and kidney
failure wouldn't he use the term renal
failure instead since he's being all
technical with a slow heartbeat
diagnosis I'll have what she's having
taking meg Ryan in vain what I need is
an infusion of vitality of youth I want
that truck David and I want it now most
of the time this show is gross literally
and figuratively insanely melodramatic
and just flat-out bad but it also
brought a lot of great performances from
Jessica Lange back into our lives and
for that I'll take us in off authorities
now believe they have found the last
known location of a missing girl
the thing about news position is how
often it makes no sense to the situation
cousin Bette here has decided to bury
her evening in a mountain of cocaine and
some Iron Butterfly oh and also the ten
o'clock news we
or organic matter we are animals we rot
we die the actual circle of life that
Disney doesn't want you to know about
man cigarettes go great after everything
right a good meal sex literally sucking
the soul out of a person wait what's
with this fruit bowl it's like seven
lemons in one block that is one terribly
unbalanced fruit bowl yes when life
gives you lemons you make lemonade but
when life gives you seven lemons in one
lime you can make lemonade and like half
a sprite
if you don't hit your mark that like
can't hit you after this Madison makes a
heavy light falling on her director and
this is why she's at the academy now but
who knew she was responsible for this
and had the power to center of this
school maybe she's 17 and her mom was
there but the clues we've been given
suggests that Madison was already an
established well-known movie star Plus
unlike Zoe she knew she could do this so
therefore whoever sent her to the school
must of tricked her or is stronger than
her to drag her to this place okay I
have so many questions but I can't
possibly watch the rest of this season
to get the answers I need cool concept
how does that work exactly can queenie
just think about who she wants to hurt
and to kill someone would mean she would
have to kill herself right I'm sure the
show has thought this through and will
give us a very detailed explanation of
how our powers work not hungry anyway or
not frat party tonight just got the
tweet you mean you just saw the tweet
dm's you get texts you get herpes you
get butt tweets you see I don't have a
broom that's ironic it's like no brains
in your horror show a plot twist that
you already know [ __ ] wouldn't have
killed you
maybe not but would it kill you to shoot
a single straight shot I haven't seen
Dutch angles this pointless and drastic
since Battlefield Earth and at least
that had John Travolta with dreadlocks
I was just on this wonderful spiritual
retreat with Shirley MacLaine and Sedona
Jessica Lange's activities from the
previous Thursday somehow I made it into
this episode she seemed to cower and to
hide in the shadows enough of this
melodramatic american borer story
nonsense I swear Simpsons Halloween
specials are not only ten thousand
percent more clever than this mess
they're actually scarier as well in
fairness though they both do make me
laugh do you really think with Twitter
and Facebook that of which does anything
at all she won't be videotaped but Fiona
believe anyone will actually believe
said video when they see it on social
media there are still people to believe
the earth is flat
this fret is Tau Omega Alpha which when
written looks a lot like TNA this had to
be purposeful right honestly I don't
know whether they're to be impressed or
sicken so let's just say I'm sick breast
party's about TV sense the real fun of
parties beat you to it
you to bite if you don't dam your bait
in the water frat guy uses a metaphor
that implies he wants to get his bitten
off staring staring staring staring
staring staring excitement is that your
superpower you can sense dehydration
actually it's that he's really quick and
he also has the power of being the only
interesting character in the last two
x-men movies I think rats are full of
fascists I don't mind being reduced to a
stereotype that I'm on a scholarship is
this how Ryan Murphy thinks young people
talk because I think Wes Craven had a
better handle on this and my soul to
take and that included a scene that
contained this exchange
did you fall I was burying a friend my
condor brandon ruin did i give it a
decent burial I can't find her anywhere
well you think she ditched you I never
had an issue finding people at college
parts and you want to know why because
99% of college parties are 30 to 40
people max and none of them take place
at dayglo Tabernacles bus split that's
not easy but you were a sloppy rich
[ __ ] I think there's about a 67 percent
chance that Murphy set this season in
the world of witchcraft because he
wanted to have a character say which
[ __ ] is something that subtle rhyme so
very subtle where are we going it's too
hot my freaking vagina's sweaty and I am
now strangely aroused we all have our
weights to bear medicine when witches
don't fight with birth this is seriously
the worst field trip ever really I once
went on a field trip to a city dump and
had to help burn trash for the day but
yeah you're probably right
getting to walk around one of the
coolest cities on the face of the earth
is way worse Madison and you're a real
witch this is brain you know that one
she's smarter than all of you put
together
yeah but she's clairvoyant if I could
read minds and see the future I would be
pretty smart too I would also be wealthy
living on a private island and not at
some witch finishing school house
amazing I am faced off
correct the actor Nicolas Cage was a
previous owner if you're the type of
person who brings up face off in casual
conversation don't you know who the
Nicolas Cage is considering all the
heinous I've had to suffer through so
far from this show I want to take a sin
off for Angela Bassett showing up
because she's the but also you've had
Angela Bassett in the back pocket this
whole time and she's just now making an
appearance
god dammit Ryan Murphy Plus mean girl
which is and more Waiting to Exhale the
potion inflicted its cruel justice and
she got what she richly deserved and the
pops fountain managers need to hire
better writers for the tour guys the
potion inflicted it's cruel justice
isn't this as bad as starting your novel
with it was a dark and stormy night
so this witch's power is literally just
the kill part of marry kill also even
with that power this is the way you
chose to kill them I think there might
be a few easier and less DNA leaving
ways to do this instead of literally his
brains out I thank you but you're never
gonna remember any of this any yeah but
you could still thank them also if
someone could use their witchy men and
black powers on me so I could forget the
last 49 minutes I would thank you better
what do you think I say when I go to the
feed store in town oh now Wally give me
a bag of the Effie pig feed 10 pounds
that [ __ ] leak out card remember they
love money so just pretend like you want
to go mine and you're in the club it's
not your fault baby look at me son it's
not your fault do you really think with
Twitter and Facebook that of which does
anything at all she won't be videotaped
and turned into some viral freak show
like a dog who says I love you this is
my life you can't come in here and piss
all over it and you can't piss on
hospitality I won't allow it and then
you can explain to them why you think
it's a bad idea for the supreme to teach
them this thing gets any worse you're
gonna want to be off the roads and on a
damn horse trust me excuse me you can't
just barge in on the tour
without purchasing a ticket you're
giving us a tour for free